hey guys how's it going it's Justine oh
boy we're back with the pizzaz plus
rotating oven so you didn't boxing not
too long ago over this thing and I made
some little pizza snacks and that got me
thinking what else could I make in this
thing so in the instructions that has
some times on how long you need to bake
things that you put on it it's weird
because I don't see a time for mac and
cheese I also don't see a time for eggs
I would like to see if I can make an egg
on this thing grilled sandwich s'mores
oh sweet baby today we are going to try
to make mac and cheese and an egg in the
rotating oven so first steps we need to
plug it in to get it real fired up and
real spicy and warm that signifies that
the oven is in fact on it's rotating
everything looks good still smells like
burning flesh
should I spray the pan like you can't
hurt okay so we've got three options
lower duel upper we're gonna do dual tri
spray the whole thing it smells like pee
what the heck what awful smell I feel
like we're gonna have is this is gonna
cook extremely slow my egg is gonna cook
extremely fast this is gonna take like
45 minutes how do I even think that this
is a good idea
Oh see yeah this is a really really bad
idea I am just thinking about all of the
things that are gonna go wrong I guess
I'll start cooking my egg on the other
side what could go wrong this is like
science a lot of science what that's
just so that's not gonna work out like
it's touching my mac and cheese it's
times like these when I assess what I'm
like doing with my life is your future
bright the egg is definitely cooking
she's so stupid
this is stats little Dom just like those
old school videos I feel like the will
it blend you
cook but there's no original ideas
anymore I'll think of an idea and I'll
do it and someone will say so-and-so has
already done that like I don't even know
who so-and-so is thanks beautiful mac
and cheese is not doing as quickly as
I'd like it's you maybe I need to push
it to the side I'm gonna get hurt I'm
pretty impressed with the egg this look
that looks good it looks like a very
nice egg should I flip the egg I think
I'm just gonna let it go oh it should
probably seize and add a little
seasoning to my egg if pepper fantastic
oh that's great it's nice well that's
nice yeah look great a little bit of
basil okay yeah I'm oh that's getting
everywhere those like air blowing that's
bad okay cool
well if I ever end up on chopped again
my recommendation is use the pizzaz
pizza no don't because you only have 30
minutes to cook and this takes for
freaking ever I mean to be fair I think
the egg is done I might want to flip it
back is this some sort of air bubble
they call it sunny-side up a sunny-side
up egg oh no oh it looks like it has
scales on it that's absolutely gross
come here Oh God I'm still frozen in the
inside
well I guess I'll try the egg while this
is doing whatever the heck it's doing
egg taste test
Oh pot
it's actually working the egg was okay I
don't think I recommend ever really
actually using this except for pizza and
stuff but look this mac and cheese it's
cooked this is definitely not the most
efficient way to do this I mean there's
some really gross crusty stuff going on
here oh there's a little bit of egg in
there too a nice little taste John do
you want to see what's happening I mean
it's kind of what it looks like when you
stick in the microwave anyway you think
this looks good
get your hair away this is dangerous do
you want those luscious locks to go up
in flames I did you try it no do you
want to try it yeah it's actually really
good it's even better if you eat it
right off the fresh piping hot pan
piping hot paint haha kind of smells
like egg well that makes sense good yeah
it worked and what's the worst that can
happen if nothing bad even happened
that's just gross bye
well now that I'm having my lunch
there's nothing more to say it worked
and nothing went wrong so what's the
worst that can happen I mean there's a
lot of things that could have went wrong
but they did not is there anything that
you guys might like me to try to bake in
here next to let me know in the comments
I'll see you guys the next video I'm
pretty proud of my creations I made an
egg and mac and cheese in the possess
this pizzazz plus rotating oven should
we get a slo-mo cheese shot oh yeah
slow-mo sizzle
see you guys later
[Music]